merci la parole est à monsieur arnaud
robinet ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de l'agriculture
après le temps des engagements vient le
temps des reniements et après le temps
des reniements vient le temps du
châtiment le châtiment électorale qui
vous a tort monsieur le ministre
j'ignore quelle ampleur il prendra
surtout quand je vois le peu de français
qui approuvent l'action du chef de
l'état
mis à part quelques stars ou vedettes
privilégiées mais en attendant
j'aimerais vous interroger sur une
promesse que le candidat hollande avait
formulé et que le président hollande à
renier une de plus cette promesse
concerne la retraite des agriculteurs en
2012 vous vous êtes engagés par écrit à
revaloriser les pensions agricoles en
faisant appel jeu suite à la solidarité
nationale afin d'améliorer le niveau des
pensions servies
jusqu'ici tout va bien le problème c'est
qu'à force de distribuer des cadeaux aux
uns et aux autres à force de jouer les
vrp dû raser gratis
vous et vos collègues finissait par
faire appel non plus à la solidarité
nationale mais aux agriculteurs
eux-mêmes qui se retrouvent donc voir
exploser leurs cotisations et leur impôt
sur les revenus du capital
vous proposez ainsi d'augmenter les
cotisations retraite des actifs de 66%
alors que 30% de l'agriculteur nouveau
aujourd'hui avec 350 euros par mois le
fardeau fiscal que vous fait peser sur
le monde agricole n'est clairement pas
supportable enfin j'ajoute monsieur le
ministre que vos promesses non financées
entraîneront selon les chiffres de la
mutuelle sociale agricole
l'épuisement des réserves des caisses de
retraite complémentaire autrement dit
votre gouvernement réussit le tour de
force de faire trinquer les actifs comme
les retraités tout en portant gravement
atteinte à la pérennité du système des
retraites des agriculteurs
monsieur le ministre vous allez recevoir
les acteurs du dossier dans quelques
jours ma question est simple
qui va payer le prix de votre à
conséquence qui va payer le prix de
votre démagogie des agriculteurs actifs
les retraités les contribuables dans
leur ensemble il nous faut des réponses
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ce
présent le seul hic est d'abord je
voudrais rappeler que je ne sais pas ce
que vient faire le châtiment là dedans
la question des retraites c'est
suffisamment sérieux pour que surtout du
côté de cet hémicycle
on rappelle à tout le monde et aux
agriculteurs en particulier que ce qui
avait été engagé en 2001 sous le
gouvernement de lionel jospin
la revalorisation soins à 75% du smic
des retraites agricoles a été stoppée en
en disant que c'est ce gouvernement qui
a repris ce travail pour augmenter à
nouveau les retraites agricoles dénoncé
depuis longtemps par tous les petits
retraités agricoles nous sommes
effectivement et nous avons mis en
oeuvre la revalorisation à 75% des
retraites des petites retraites
agricoles
ça vous fait peut-être difficulté de le
dire mais c'est la réalité
quant à la rc eau et la revalorisation
des retraites en particulier pour les
femmes dans l'agriculture
c'est près d'un milliard d'euros depuis
trois ans qui ont permis une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités agricoles pour les femmes qui
ont travaillé dans les exploitations
agricoles
ça mérite de temps en temps d'être
rappelés et d'être salué enfin vous avez
évoqué ce que serait châtiment qui avait
trois sujets qui étaient évoquées dans
l'accord que nous avions passé un un
financement sur le fonds de roulement de
la msa qui a été utilisée de il y avait
une partie d'augmentation de cotisations
sociales pour financer les retraites à
1,3 en termes de taux de cotisation et
troisième pilier sur lequel on
s'habillait c'était une remise à plat
des exonérations de cotisations par des
optimisations qui était fait sur
l'utilisation du foncier sur ce point là
nous avons effectivement constaté
malheureusement que ce que nous avions
anticipé comme retraite comme recette
était bien inférieur à ce que nous
avions anticipé du fait d'une
optimisation continue qui n'a pas permis
d'avoir la recette donc nous aurons le
30 novembre avec l'ensemble des acteurs
une discussion pour revaloriser les
retraites et la parole